[Music]
let's go to laura in flushing the
commode new york what's up laura i
couldn't i'm sorry laura i'm sorry
hi hey john how are you i'm good i know
your town is named flushing and i made a
commod joke and i'm sorry i couldn't
help it i tried
everybody does that it's okay i know i
don't want to be everybody but i
couldn't help it i would love to live in
a town called flushing that would be so
awesome it's basically new york city but
yeah
[Laughter]
well my name is used to name toilets too
and john so here we go so hey what's up
laura how how can i help
well first i just want to um thank you
for you know taking my call as quickly
as you did i found you on youtube
literally
the same night i called you and it's
just remarkable so thank you well that's
awesome thanks for calling in thanks for
watching youtube i don't even know how
to log into that but it sounds like it's
a fun little uh thing that that people
watch sounds awesome yeah well that's
awesome so what's up how can i help
well um so basically um
i am in
a i've known my fiance for four years we
got engaged
this may i live in new york city he
lives in kentucky
and everything was good up until
two years ago because
um
okay so i'm 28 years old um i live with
my parents they're in the early 60s they
married in the 80s
and
we now me my mom and my sister
we found out that my dad was cheating on
my mom with different women all the
years of
their marriage
the first the first time we found this
out
it was well at least i wasn't born yet
but my mom found out in 1990 when my
sister was a baby
and and a woman and a woman called the
house and
okay but fast forwarding to today two
years ago um
thanks to the power of the internet we
found out through emails he was emailing
lots of different women he was trying to
hook up with
none of which accepted his offer so he
kept getting turned down to her downturn
down but all
all our lives for me my sister he was
trying to hook up with different women
okay and
and two years ago we found this out
and this has created immense
trust issues between me and my fiance
i do not know how to trust men and
and there's there's more to the story
but i'll let you
what's the more to the story
well
so my father is not only
a
um a downright a-hole and a cheater but
he is also a black mailer meaning
when we found out what my dad was doing
he
to my mom at first and myself included
because i live with my parents
we started to you know say you know how
could you do this
mommy's loved you for for all these
years she's been faithful to you she
cleaned your clothes washed makes your
food etc
and um
at first you know we were telling him
this
and then
my dad decided to try to commit suicide
in front of my mom every chance he got
and this
has been daily sometimes i've had to
call the police
and take him to the hospital and they've
only kept him one night
no medication
nothing and he only does this suicide
thing in front of my mom not me or my
sister or my sister's or my sister or
her husband who lives on the seventh
floor
um
[Music]
and
he doesn't do this in front of me
and this has created immense
trust issues between me and my fiance i
do not know how to trust men and i'm
terrified to get married
and we when we fight and then
his name is daniel we fight
every single day is daniel a good man
absolutely
he he doesn't um he hasn't
um he doesn't raise his voice to me
daniel
yeah he so hold on lord
your dad is sick
yes he is
i'm sick
it's a mess
and one of the most devastating things
about
infidelity
especially pervasive ongoing infidelity
that goes over years and years and years
there is the oh my gosh i met somebody
at work and it was three weeks and
suddenly turned into a thing into a
thing there's that
there's the work event one night of
stand
then there's the pervasive
over a series of years
betrayal
there's the betrayal that sucks tears
your soul out from you
but i believe that one of the worst if
not the worst outcome of
that type of betrayal that type of
infidelity
is it causes people to doubt themselves
how did i miss this it makes you feel
crazy
and you have had a working picture of a
dad and i bet if you're honest he wasn't
a great dad either
oh no on the contrary that's right so so
you
everything about him says not safe not
healthy not well not a person of
character all those things
mushed up into one thing
and it has made you feel nuts
why can't this guy act like an adult why
won't this man love me he's my dad
why won't he love my mom
she seems great to me you feel crazy and
you're not
okay
oh well yeah no um i just i just want to
reiterate um
this has become a total shock to me only
only about my dad only because
he he was a good father to me and my
sister he supported us when whatever we
did um it's just that his marriage with
my mom was doomed from the start oh not
only because of the infidelities but
because they are just so completely
opposite
their marriage was doomed because
they didn't choose both of them
to work on it to stay connected into it
to decide we are both super opposite
we're going to make this thing work
we're going to lean into it and i'll
give them the benefit of the doubt they
didn't have the tools the ideas that all
the stuff all the pictures all that
stuff
but here's the thing
you're here now
and you're dating a guy named dan who's
a great guy right
for four years
you're engaged to him okay
you have a singular hard chat decision
to make a challenge ahead of you
your body now does not trust men
because the one who was dead
destroyed it
destroyed your trust
is that fair can i just interrupt for a
quick second yeah
um my sister's husband like i said they
live on the seventh floor um he he he is
also the same type of person he's
cheated on my sister all the years
they've known each other
and uh
my sister's the exact same way as my mom
because they now have to keep quiet
otherwise the men in their life
literally try to commit suicide if they
if they don't shut up about about it
so it's not just my father it's my
sister so then you got two of them
yes two men who are very close to you
are running a great scam and they're not
well
both and
i'm gonna challenge you your parent your
mother and your sister need to get away
from these men these abusive
um
gaslighting
men who lack character and who are
incredibly unwell
they need to distance themselves from
them
they can choose not to and say it's
because they're trying to keep them
alive and all those things
but they need to leave that's another
call
i'm going to continue to push back to
right now you
because you can't control them the only
thing on planet earth you can control
laura is
your thoughts and your actions that's it
i'm very well aware of that yeah that's
that's why i called you i love it i love
it so
your body's gonna respond to trust and
intimacy with men
as though it is a terrifying thing
that's going to get you hurt because
that's what it's experienced and that's
fair that your body's trying to take
care of you that way
okay
has daniel done anything to
show you that he is not worthy of your
trust
absolutely not
however i just have to say
because of what has happened
and i'm afraid to trust men so ardently
i
i keep thinking he thinks he thinks this
cashier is hot he thinks this lady on tv
is hot i i want to be the constant
this constant sex idol then break up
with him
just break up with him i think you
should break up with him and just move
on with your life and be single for the
rest of your life
well i i don't i don't want to do that
okay then if you don't want to do that
and i was being an idiot of course not
do that of course i know it sounded
funny what i just said no no it doesn't
it doesn't it sounds defeatist and i get
it
you've earned a fetish
life has thrown you crap
your brother-in-law sucks
your dad sucks
and i know that sounds mean to say it
like that but it's true
i know it's true
dan doesn't
and
you have those thoughts and they are
real and they pop into your head and
then when they pop in you have a choice
and that is am i going to meditate on
these am i going to try to become them
am i going to try to live into them am i
going to throw them on my fiancee who i
love
or am i going to heal from these things
so that over time
i'm able to trust dan he is going to be
my refuge in this world of insanity
that's the choice you have
otherwise you are choosing to make
yourself miserable and by proxy make him
miserable and i don't think he deserves
it do you
no and the fights have become so
frequent he he was supposed to visit new
york in november and he keeps putting it
off because he's afraid i'm gonna start
screaming at him are you
yes you are
what do you mean
think of it this way your dad dumped a
bucket of crap on you
and every time you're around dan you
take some of it and throw it at him
just because he might he might have some
too
and if i'm him i don't want to be around
that
he's probably trying to love the woman
of his life the best he can through
trauma and through this these
revelations
and you're hitting him for it
i have to admit he has been very
extremely not very extremely patient
through all of this
laura do you want to hurt
forever
no okay i don't
every time you scream every time you
yell every time you start a fight
it's a choice to be miserable
every time
every time you hold secrets back from
daniel it's a choice to
um
put a wedge in your relationship
you know what's crazy though there are
no secrets between us i i have this
weird thing about me where i don't know
how to
lie it's just crazy
in a in a previous episode we recorded
recently
we talked about um
there's a difference between no secrets
and being honest and oversharing being
being weaponizing
truth
there is something
spoiler alert your husband's gonna find
other women attractive throughout his
life it's gonna happen
he's gonna see somebody be like wow
beautiful
you're gonna have to get over that
and you're gonna see people and think
they're super good looking too
i actually won't believe it or not i i
know myself i won't you're super super
incorrect on that but it's cool you can
live in that fantasy right now that's a
different phone call you for sure will
and that's okay that's not infidelity
that means you don't love each other
that means you're human
what i'm hearing over and over and over
laura
is you don't want to heal right now and
you don't have to that's your
prerogative you want to not hurt and i
believe that
but you don't want to do the hard hard
work to heal from what has happened to
you
you don't
you want to rage and unfortunately a guy
you love
and if who wants to marry you
is the target of your rage
and if i'm him i'm not sticking around
for that
we're not married yet i don't have to
i'm out
because i'm just trying to love you the
best i can and you're taking it out on
me over and over and over again
your body is right to be scared of men
they've hurt you and those you love fair
daniel has not
you have to come up to a come up to a
place in your relationship where you can
say hey i'm my heart is racing right now
as though you've done something and i
know you haven't
but i'm feeling super anxious right now
about our relationship
and because you've been through trauma
and he loves you he can say
thank you for sharing that with me i
love you i'm committed to you i'll never
cheat on you never have and you go okay
thank you
that's it
no screaming no fights no anger no rage
no none of that stuff
that's not gonna solve or heal or help
anything
nothing it's a choice to stay in the
sewer system that your brother-in-law
and dad drag you down into
now
daniel's gonna get some crap on him
because he's gonna hug you
not cause you're gonna throw it at him
and when you hug somebody who's hurting
you get their blood and guts and crap on
you that's part of love that's what love
is
b doesn't deserve to be have it thrown
at him
you have to decide
do i want to have a healthy marriage
do i want to work through my fear of men
do i want to honor and love this guy
daniel who honors and loves me do i want
joy in my life or do i just want to be
miserable
you are not trapped you're making some
choices
hard call laura
i don't think you're ready i think
you're still too angry and still too
full of rage
but i wish you peace i tell you what i
wish you peace
i really do